Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In 1885, the French Catholic Church celebrated a spectacular propaganda coup. One of its fiercest critics, the anti-clerical writer Léo Taxil, had at last seen the light and was eager to tell the world about his conversion. Above all, Taxil was determined to expose the grotesque and hateful network to which he had belonged since his teens, the diabolical world of Freemasonry. The great architect of the Masons, Taxile announced, was the devil. Their lodges housed
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1885年，法国天主教会大肆庆祝了一场轰动的宣传胜利。其最激烈的批评者之一、反教权主义作家莱奥·塔克希尔（Léo Taxil）终于大彻大悟，渴望向全世界倾诉他皈依的过程。最重要的是，塔克希尔决心揭露他自青少年时期以来一直所属的那个怪诞而充满仇恨的网络，即充满恶魔色彩的共济会世界。塔克希尔宣称，共济会的伟大建筑师就是魔鬼。他们的会所里藏有
statues of goat-headed beasts. Their rituals involved bestial forms of carnality and prostitution, last seen in ancient Babylon. The worst masons of all were the new reformed Palladians, led by a devil-worshipping lesbian called Sister Sophia Sappho. In public, Sophia Sappho seemed a genteel spinster. But in private, she would writhe with passion as she spat on a consecrated host before forcing a newly initiated sister to have sex with the sacramental bread stuffed up her vagina. Published in a series of best-selling books, Taxil's revelations transfixed France. He was invited to an audience with Pope Leo XIII, who told him that he had read every word. And then, after 12 years of headlines, Taxil called a public meeting at the Geographical Society in Paris and revealed the truth.
羊头野兽的雕像。他们的仪式涉及野蛮的肉欲和卖淫形式，这些恶习自古代巴比伦以后就销声匿迹了。所有共济会成员中最坏的是新革新帕拉第安派，由一个崇拜魔鬼的女同性恋者索菲娅·萨福修女（Sister Sophia Sappho）领导。在公众面前，索菲娅·萨福似乎是一个温文尔雅的老处女。但在私底下，她会狂热地扭动身体，向被祝圣过的圣饼吐口水，然后强迫一个刚入会的修女将塞进阴道里的圣餐饼拿出来发生性关系。塔克希尔的这些爆料通过一系列畅销书发表，震撼了整个法国。他应邀获得了教皇利奥十三世的接见，教皇告诉他，他连一个字都没落下全读完了。然后，在经历了12年的头条新闻之后，塔克希尔在巴黎地理学会召开了一场公开会议，并揭露了真相。
So Dominic, as you will well know, that's a review by a top critic of the book, The Craft, How the Freemasons Made the Modern World by John Dickey, who is Professor of Italian Studies at University College London. And that top critic was yourself. Yes. So that is the ultimate Sunday Times review opening. So that's the kind of thing that the literature of the day loved. He always used to say, loads of sex, please. And so when I came across this in this wonderful book,
所以，多米尼克，正如你所熟知的，那是顶级评论家对《共济会：共济会员如何塑造现代世界》（The Craft: How the Freemasons Made the Modern World）一书的评论。该书作者是伦敦大学学院意大利研究教授约翰·迪基（John Dickey）。而那位顶级评论家就是你自己。没错。所以那是《星期日泰晤士报》式的终极书评开场。所以那是当时文学界非常喜欢的东西。他总是说，多来点色情内容，拜托。所以当我在这本精彩的书里看到这个时，
it's one of those books, actually, The Craft, it's called. And it's one of those books where, as you read it, the scales kind of fall from your eyes. Because I had always been interested in who were the Freemasons? Where did they come from? What do they believe? Is that, Dominic, because you yourself are a Freemason? No, I'm not. I'm absolutely not, Tom.
这本书其实就是那种书，书名叫《共济会》。当你阅读它时，你会有一种眼界大开的感觉。因为我一直对这些问题很感兴趣：共济会员是谁？他们从哪里来？他们信仰什么？多米尼克，这是因为你自己就是一个共济会员吗？不，我不是。绝对不是，汤姆。
But as you are now going to say of course i would say that uh wouldn't i if i was part of this diabolical conspiracy as we will see the truth that tax seal reveals is is is surprising shall we say so are we going to reveal the truth now i think should we get um should we get the author of the book that you reviewed who is has very kindly agreed to come on the show and talk about free masons Should we get him to tell us what the truth was? I suspect we should. So, John Dickey, thank you so much for joining us. A wonderful book. Now, come on, Leo Taxil. Was he telling the truth about Sister Sophia Sappho and the New Reform Palladians and the devil or not? Well, it's great to be here. And I'm tempted to suggest that people read the book to find out,
但正如你现在肯定要说的，如果我是这个邪恶阴谋的一部分，我当然会这么说，不是吗？正如我们将会看到的，塔克希尔揭露的真相可以说是相当惊人。那么我们现在要揭示真相吗？我想，我们是不是该把……我们是不是该请你评论过的那位书的作者上节目，他非常慷慨地答应来到节目中谈论共济会员。我们应该让他来告诉我们真相是什么吗？我想我们应该的。所以，约翰·迪基，非常感谢你加入我们。一本好书。那么，说真的，关于莱奥·塔克希尔。关于索菲娅·萨福修女、新革新帕拉第安派以及恶魔的事，他说的是真的还是假的？嗯，很高兴来到这里。我很想建议人们去读这本书以找出答案，
but perhaps I'm not giving away too much by saying it was actually a gigantic hoax. I mean, one of the biggest hoaxes in modern history that certainly had large parts of the Catholic Church fooled and lasted 12 years, and tells us a lot about this still ongoing paranoia that the Catholic Church has about Freemasonry. But there'll be lots of people listening to this who will say, okay, fine, well, it wasn't, you know, okay, maybe the Freemasons aren't devil-worshipping lesbians. But there are still all kinds of mysterious things.
不过，我说这其实是一场巨大的骗局，可能也不算剧透太多。我的意思是，这是现代历史上最大的骗局之一，它确实愚弄了天主教会的很大一部分人，持续了12年之久，这也充分说明了天主教会至今对共济会仍然抱有的那种持续不断的偏见。但这里会有很多听众会说，好吧，行吧，事情并非如此，也许吧，也许共济会员不是崇拜魔鬼的女同性恋者。但仍然有各种各样神秘的事情。
It's a network that, you know, people of our generation always talk about the police in Britain that has infiltrated this institution, that institution. So when you come to write about it as a historian, to what extent were you yourself, you know, how much of that did you have in your head? Because you've written about the mafia before, haven't you? So you're very good on shadowy, sinister organisations. Yeah, I came to it through the mafia, really, haven't you? So you're very good on shadowy, sinister organizations. Yeah, I came to it through the Mafia, really, because I'd been on radio a lot, TV a lot, talking about the Mafia. And when asked to define the Mafia, I did exactly the way Sicilian Mafiosi do. And I said, well, it's like a Freemasonry for criminals. And I got a message from the head of communications at the United
这是一个网络，你知道的，我们这一代人总是在谈论英国警方如何渗透了这个机构、那个机构。所以当你作为一名历史学家去书写它时，你在多大程度上，你知道的，你脑子里有多少这样的想法？因为你以前写过关于黑手党的内容，对吧？所以你非常擅长描写这种隐秘、阴险的组织。是的，我确实是通过黑手党接触到这个主题的，对吧？所以你非常擅长描写这种隐秘、阴险的组织。是的，我确实是通过黑手党接触到这个主题的，因为我经常上广播和电视节目谈论黑手党。当被要求定义黑手党时，我完全采用了西西里黑手党成员的做法。我说，这就像是犯罪分子的共济会。然后我收到了英国联合总会（United Grand Lodge of England）传播主管发来的一条消息，说：你想不想过来聊聊，因为我们的成员都非常愤怒。于是我就去了，跟他们聊了聊，还参观了博物馆。基于我之前对意大利语境下的共济会的了解。特别是，我意识到这里有一个重大的故事，因为外界关于共济会员的叙事其实只有两种。一种是阴谋论，或者是一种肮脏的小集团，也就是我们从小听惯了的故事。另一种你在外界能听到的叙事则是共济会员自己的版本，那就是
Grand Lodge of England at the end of the day saying, would you like to come in for a chat because our members are up in arms. So I went along and had a chat with them and did the tour of the museum. And based on what I already kind of knew about Freemasonry in the Italian context. Particularly, I realized there was a big story there because there are really only two narratives out there about the Freemasons. One is this sort of either it's a conspiracy theory or it's a sort of grubby cabal, the kind of story we grew up with. Or on the other story that you have out there is the Freemasons version, which
这一切都是一种高尚且被误解的传统，关乎兄弟情谊、慈善工作之类的事情。这两种说法都有一些真实成分，取决于你在历史上走到哪个阶段，以及你在世界各地走到哪里，因为共济会是一个全球现象。但在中间有非常多的内容是这两种说法都没有捕捉到的。这真的非常有意思。我的意思是，我写书从未像写这本时这样充满乐趣。但另一个我一直有所察觉、却在读你的书之前从未真正理清头绪的谜团，就是它的起源。因为关于起源的故事，共济会员自己声称，我是说，这可以追溯到所罗门王以及在耶路撒冷建造圣殿的石匠的时代。
is it's all a noble and misunderstood tradition of brotherhood and charity work and that sort of thing. And both of those stories have some elements of truth in them, depending on where you go in history and where you go across the world, because Freemasonry is a global phenomenon. But there's an awful lot in the middle that neither of those stories captured. And that is huge fun. I mean, I've never had so much fun writing a book as I did writing this one. But the other mystery that I've always kind of been aware of and never, until I read your book, probably got a handle on is the origins. Because the origin story, the Freemasons themselves say, I mean, it goes back to the time of Solomon and Masons building the temple in Jerusalem.
圣殿骑士团不知怎么也牵涉其中，他们崇拜一个叫巴风特（Baphomet）的恶魔头像。光明会不知怎么也在那里。在这股具有历史主题的阴谋论漩涡中，共济会员似乎就坐在正中央。我猜，在某种程度上，这种神秘感，我的意思是，这正是共济会员觉得好玩的大部分原因。但话说回来，共济会员诞生的实际历史到底是怎样的？据推测，它不可能追溯到中世纪，更不用说追溯到所罗门王的时代了。不，我是说，你真的需要看看共济会发展过程中的两个关键时刻。一个是16世纪末苏格兰国王詹姆斯六世（即后来的英格兰国王詹姆斯一世）的宫廷，
And somehow the Templars fit in and they worship a head of a demon called Baphomet. And somehow the Illuminati are there as well. And that great swirl of historically themed conspiracy theories, the Freemasons seem to be sat right in the middle of it. And I'm guessing that in part, the secrecy of that is, I mean, it's a huge part of the fun for the Freemasons. But also, what is the actual history of how the Freemasons came to being? Presumably, it doesn't go back to the Middle Ages, let alone back to the time of Solomon. No. I mean, you really need to look at two moments that were the key moments in the development of Freemasonry. One was the court of James VI of Scotland, future James I of England, at the very end of the 16th century,
当时石匠们形成了一种传说。石匠们创造了他们自己的一套企业神话（如果你愿意这么叫的话），其中包含了所有这些东西，比如欧几里得、所罗门圣殿以及所有诸如此类的东西。通过一次非常有趣的政治运作，一个名叫威廉·肖（William Shaw）的人——他是詹姆斯一世的工程大臣，也就是公共工程大臣——与这些高级石匠结成了某种联盟。这些石匠当时正在建造诸如詹姆斯在斯特灵城堡的新小礼拜堂之类的建筑，据了解，威廉·肖向他们引进了某种版本的文艺复兴哲学、
when you had a sort of law, L-O-R-E, of stonemasons. Stonemasons had created their own sort of corporate mythology, if you like, that included all of these things like Euclid and Solomon's Temple and all of that sort of stuff. And in a very interesting political move, a man called William Shaw, S-C-H-A-W, who was James I's basically Minister of Works, Minister of Public Works, made a kind of alliance with these senior stonemasons who were building things like James' new chapel at Stirling Castle and introduced them, it seems, to certain versions of Renaissance philosophy,
古典哲学，尤其是记忆术（the art of memory），我确信你们对这都很了解。这种想法是，你通过想象穿过整座建筑来背诵一篇演讲，建筑里有各种东西，比如有趣的地板、记忆宫殿、这里的柱子和那里的图片等等。在文艺复兴时期，文艺复兴时期的赫密士主义（Hermeticism）哲学成为了通往宇宙秘密的一种门户。
classical philosophy, and particularly the art of memory, which I'm sure you know all about. The idea that you memorize a speech by visualizing going through a whole building with various things like an interesting floor, memory palace, or columns here and pictures there and that kind of thing. And in the Renaissance, the Renaissance philosophy of Hermeticism, that became a sort of portal to the secrets of the universe.
威廉·肖向这些石匠介绍了这种神话，抱歉，是这种文艺复兴时期的哲学，作为一种讨好的姿态（如果你愿意这么说的话），并且承诺帮助他们组织起来。这很适合他们的一种需求——要成为一名石匠，你必须在神话等方面背诵相当多的内容。这帮助他们组织了入会仪式。它赋予了、将他们组织中被称为会所（lodges）的单元变成了记忆剧场。如果你今天去参观共济会会所或共济会圣殿，你会看到棋盘格的地板。你会看到柱子、地球仪和各种移动的符号，它们都是记忆辅助工具，是助记符，用来帮助你在漫长而复杂的仪式中自如穿行。
And William Shaw introduced these stonemasons to this mythology to this sorry this renaissance philosophy as a sort of flattering overture if you like and uh promised to help them organize themselves and that suited their sort of they had to become a stonemason, you had to memorize quite a lot in terms of the mythology and so on and so forth. It helped them organize their initiation rituals. It gave, it turned the cells of their organization that they called lodges into theaters of memory. And if you go to a Masonic lodge today, a Masonic temple, you will see a chessboard floor. You will see columns and globes and various symbols moving around that are a memoir, they're mnemonics to help you negotiate your way through the long and complicated rituals.
而新颖且令人兴奋的想法是，这具有某种哲学内容，这让你得以接触到某种真理，无论是伦理真理还是哲学真理。各种各样不同的真理都被叠加在这上面。所以这是第一个时刻。正是在那个时刻，它开始变得时髦起来，绅士们开始加入这些石匠会所，去寻找当时时髦的知识分子关注点。它在全国范围内传播开来，尽管形式非常
And the new and exciting idea was that this had a kind of philosophical content, that this was giving you access to some kind of truth, whether it be an ethical truth or a philosophical truth. All sorts of different kinds of truth have been superimposed on that. So that's the one moment. And at that moment, it becomes fashionable, gentlemen start to join these lodges of stonemasons in search of fashionable, intellectual concerns of the age. And it spreads around the country, albeit in very
小规模且低调。你说的全国是指英国还是仅仅指苏格兰？它进入了英格兰。我的意思是，主要的途径之一似乎是参与内战（即英国内战）的苏格兰军队。到了18世纪初，它在某种程度上已经成为了全国性的，但似乎相当缺乏协调。然后我们迎来了第二个重大时刻，那是在1717年，当时有四个会所联合起来创立了所谓的总会所（grand lodge），这是一个监督机构，负责执行规则并决定谁是合法的共济会员，谁不是。在这个时候，
sort of small and low-key forms. And by country, you mean Britain or just Scotland? It enters England. I mean, one of the main vehicles seems to have been Scottish forces involved in the Civil War, the Civil Wars. And it's by the beginning of the 18th century, it's kind of national, but rather uncoordinated, it seems. And then we get the second big moment, which is in 1717, when a group of four lodges come together to found what's called a grand lodge, a sort of supervisory body to enforce the rules and decide who is legitimately a Freemason and who isn't. At this time,
他们开始称自己为共济会员（Freemasons）。谁是共济会员，谁又不是，在这个时候他们开始称自己为共济会员。共济会员是指自由地用石头工作，而不是像奴隶一样盲目切割的人，对吗？这就是这个词的起源。但它在资料中有多种含义。它保留了它的原始含义，也就是那个精心雕琢石头，然后把它交给别人砌进
they're beginning to call themselves Freemasons. And a Freemason and who isn't, at this time they're beginning to call themselves Freemasons. And a Freemason is someone who works freely with stone rather than kind of slavishly cutting, is that right? That's the origins of the word. But it has many meanings in the sources. It keeps its original meaning, which is the guy who, you know, elaborately shapes the stone and then hands it over to a guy to just bung it in a
墙壁或教堂等建筑里的家伙，嗯……但我认为关于“自由”之类的内涵，有助于它成为共济会的名字。因为到了18世纪初，嗯，共济会已经与任何真正的具体事务分离开来——事实上，1717年总会所的建立似乎是这一进程中的一个关键时刻——将自己与任何石匠工艺分离开来。石匠的装备——手套、围裙、直角尺、铅锤等各种工具——不再是石匠的工具，而仅仅变成了这些共济会仪式中隐喻性工具包的一部分。所以，约翰，他们在鹅与烤架酒吧（Goose and Gridiron pub）会面。那是在1717年。他们不是在那里商讨确立规则吗？汤姆和我之前讨论过这个。
wall or a you know church or whatever um but i think the connotations of freedom and so on um were helpful in its becoming the name for the freemasons because by the beginning of the 18th century um freemasonry has separated it off from any real concrete in fact that that foundation of the grand lodge in 1717 seems to have been a key moment in that process separated itself off from any of that stonemasonry stuff and the the accoutrements of the stonemason, the gloves, the apron, the set squares, the lead weight things, all of those sorts of tools, stop being tools of stonemasons and just become part of the metaphorical kit of these masonic rituals. So, John, they meet at the Goose and Gridiron pub. It's in 1717. Don't they to hammer it out? And Tom and I were discussing this beforehand.
我对他说，这有点像英格兰足球总会的成立，大家坐下来商定共同的规则。而汤姆则说，嗯，实际上，这是18世纪的事，所以它更像是板球规则的制定。但确实有那种感觉，不是吗？那就是有一种，你刚才谈到了绅士，这些人实际上是出身良好、受过良好教育、家境优渥的人，他们聚在一起为
I said to him that it's a bit like the foundation of the Football Association, hammering out common rules. And Tom said, well, it's actually, it's 18th century, so it's more like the rules of cricket. But there is a sense of that, isn't there, that there is a sort of, you know, you were talking about gentlemen earlier, that these are actually quite well-born, well--educated well-off people who are coming together to create the rules
一个——这虽然不太算是一场游戏，但它是一种仪式，不是吗？而且他们确实认为——我认为从你的书里能体会到的一点是——他们从一开始就认为这很有趣，这其中很重要的一部分在于，这种兄弟会元素其实相当欢乐，而不是阴险的。是的，绝对的。它是18世纪那种俱乐部世界及各种事物的一部分，在很大程度上正是其中一部分，在某种程度上是最成功、最持久的部分。而且你知道，与板球之类的比较也站得住脚，因为通过帝国，它随后传播到了全球，特别是当你在1723年建立了一本规则手册之后。是的，喝酒畅饮之类的活动一直是
of a it's not quite a game but it's a kind of ritual isn't it and they do regard it i think one of the things that comes through from your book is they regard it as fun from the beginning that there's that's an important part of it it's a kind of that sort of brotherhood element is actually quite jolly rather than sinister yeah absolutely it's part of that 18th century world of clubs and uh and all of that sort of thing very very much part of that in a way the most successful and long-lasting part of that and and you know the comparison with sort of cricket or whatever also stands up in the sense that through the empire, it's then spread around the globe, particularly once you've got a rule book set up in 1723. Yeah, boozing and drinking and so on has always been an absolutely key part of
共济会绝对核心的一部分。此外，没有女性也是另一个非常典型的18世纪俱乐部特点。是的，没错。我的意思是，共济会员一直因为这一点而受到严厉的批评，我认为这是合情合理的。但1723年的那本规则手册，也就是以其命名的《安德森宪章》（Anderson's Constitutions，即《共济会的宪章》），是第一本真正官方声明“听着，不能有任何女性，不能有任何奴隶，不能有任何，你知道的，诸如此类的人”的宪章。这引发了很多问题，你知道的，正如你从书中所了解到的那样，存在着各种形式将女性纳入其中的共济会版本，一直到完全平等的会员身份、男女混合会所。但标准仍然非常，你知道的，男性化。正如我所说，这是一本关于男性的
Freemasonry. Also, the lack of women is also another very distinctive 18th century club aspect. Yeah, that's right. I mean, the Masons have always been, quite rightly, I think, given a hard time for this. But that rule book from 1723, the Andersons' Constitutions, as it's named, the Constitutions of the Freemasons, is the first to actually officially say, look, you can't have any women, can't have any slaves, can't have any, you know, whatever. And that's created a lot of problem that, you know, as you'll know from the book, there are versions of Freemasonry that have incorporated women in various forms, right up to kind of full equal membership, mixed logics. But the norm is still, I think, very, you know, male. This is a book, as I said, about male
怪异行径及其历史的书。尽管书中确实介绍了一位可能是女性、也可能不是的人，那就是德荣骑士（Chevalier d'Eon），我猜他代表了共济会从英格兰向海峡对岸的传播。德荣骑士要么是一个女扮男装的男人，要么是一个女扮女装却假装成男人、不知怎么还成为共济会员的女人。是的，这显然引起了极大的 hilarity（欢笑）。共济会员在自己玩得开心的同时，也总是因为他们奇怪的举动——比如拉起裤腿、露出胸膛以及所有诸如此类的事情——而
eccentricity and their history. Although you do introduce someone who may have been female, or maybe not, who is the Chevalier d'Eon, who is, I guess, representative of the spread of Freemasonry from England across the channel. And the Chevalier d'Eon is either a man who dresses as a woman or a woman who dresses as a woman but pretends to be a man and somehow become a Mason. Yeah, no, it created obviously great hilarity the masons have all as well as having good time themselves have always uh provoked enormous laughs uh among everybody else because of their strange you know hauling their trouser legs up and and bearing their chests and all that kind of stuff um and uh one of my major course of hilarity during the 18th century was this story of the Chevalier d'Anne, who was basically a French spy, a French government agent, and kind of scandalous, who ended up joining a lodge in London.
引发其他人的一阵狂笑。嗯，18世纪期间我主要的笑料来源之一就是德荣骑士的故事。德荣骑士基本上是一个法国间谍、法国政府特工，而且名声狼藉，最后在伦敦加入了一个会所。由于种种原因，同样地，这个故事很复杂，取决于你相信谁，他最初是以女性身份出现的，
And for whatever reasons, again, the story is complicated, it depends who you believe, started as a woman uh and actually claiming to be a woman um and eventually would be welcomed into the bosom of freemasonry back in as it were in france yes uh where they did allow uh they did a lot they did have a form of female freemasonry at the time so-called adoption lodges. But in the meantime, there was a huge betting market opened about whether Chevalier d'Or really was or wasn't a woman. And eventually, I think probably because of bribery, somebody was, a witness came up and said,
并且实际上声称自己是一个女人，最终在法国老家重新受到了共济会的欢迎。是的，当时他们确实允许、他们确实建立了一种女性共济会的形式，即所谓的收养会所（adoption lodges）。但与此同时，当时出现了一个巨大的博彩市场，赌德荣骑士究竟是不是女人。最终，我想可能是因为贿赂，某个见证人站出来说：
well, I actually had sex with Chevalier d'Or and she's definitely a woman. And yeah, the truth wouldn't be revealed until he died. And we found out that she was anatomically male. Wow. So I'll tell you a strange thing that I had never realized before reading your book was that Freemasonry is linked to wiggery. So there's loads of wigs. It's sort of the Robert Walpole era. So is it a sort of political patronage group at this stage? Well, kind of everything is in the 18th century. But yes, I mean, they absolutely, particularly
“其实我跟德荣骑士发生过性关系，她绝对是个女人。”是的，直到他死后，真相才大白天下，我们发现他其实是生理男性。哇哦。那我告诉你一件我在读你的书之前从未意识到的奇怪事情：共济会竟然与假发文化有关。这里有大量的假发。这有点像是罗伯特·沃波尔（Robert Walpole）时代。所以这个阶段它是一个政治 patronage（政治庇护/培植羽翼）集团吗？嗯，18世纪的基本上所有东西都是。但是的，我的意思是，他们绝对如此，尤其是
because of the secrecy code they've got, which I think we probably need to get into at some stage. They need the protection of the Whig elite. What I think happened, and it's still, you know, opinions are divided among historians. What I think happened with the setting up of that Grand Lodge was that was effectively a kind of Whig coup within Freemasonry. And they elbowed out the Tories who'd previously been in charge, you know, the fate of Christopher Wren, who had been in many, it seems to have been a kind of figurehead
因为他们有保密法典，我想我们可能需要在某个阶段深入探讨这一点。他们需要辉格党精英的庇护。我认为发生的事情是——而且直到现在，历史学家们的意见仍然分歧——我认为随着那个总会所的建立，共济会内部实际上发生了一场辉格党的政变。他们挤走了以前掌权的托利党人。你知道克里斯托弗·伦（Christopher Wren）的命运，他在很多方面似乎都是
of the exception, as Freemasonry was called kind of in London before. Because he was an architect. I mean, he was literally building temples. Yes, absolutely. Yeah, and all of, you know, many, many of the builders, the contractors and people that he used in building St Paul's and all the other churches were Freemasons, were members of this thing called the Exceptions,
例外派（the Exceptions）的某种象征人物，正如伦敦以前对共济会的称呼那样。因为他是一位建筑师。我的意思是，他确实在建造圣殿。是的，绝对的。是的，而且所有，你知道的，许多建造圣保罗大教堂和其他所有教堂的建造者、承包商和工匠，都是共济会员，都是这个被称为“例外派”的组织的成员，
as was Christopher N's son, and so on and so forth. And I think what happens in the transition into the Whig regime is that they kind of want to move on from that Tory version of Freemasonry and create a new version. And so does that association of Freemasonry with kind of Whiggish principles of liberty and freedom and enlightenment thought, does that explain its success on the continent where there's this kind of Anglomania, this fascination with England as Voltaire comes here and says that it's the great home of liberty? Is that part of what explains its success? Definitely, I think so. You know, Freemasonry is a kind of vehicle of enlightenment values
克里斯托弗·伦的儿子也是如此，诸如此类。我认为在向辉格党政权的过渡中发生的事情是，他们希望摆脱共济会的那个托利党版本，创造一个新版本。那么，共济会与辉格党的自由、解放和启蒙思想等原则的这种联系，是否解释了它在欧洲大陆的成功？那里存在着一种对英国的迷恋（Anglomania），一种对英国作为伟大自由之乡的痴迷，伏尔泰来到这里并如此宣称。这是否是解释其成功的部分原因？毫无疑问，我想是的。你知道，共济会一直是启蒙运动价值观的一种载体，
again and again. And it's not just in, you know, when it's first exported to France, that people see it as something modern. But again and again, you know, we see it in the early republic in the United States or in the early movement for Indian independence. It seems to offer itself as a very good school of modern politics and of the kind of skills and values that you need to take part in a modern state. So all that sort of supreme being stuff and all the quite vague, well, the simultaneously very detailed, but also kind of vague religious stuff, my sense is that that's a product of
一次又一次。而且不仅是在它最初被出口到法国时，人们认为它是现代的事物；一次又一次，我们在美国早期共和国或印度独立运动的早期活动中也看到了这一点。它似乎将自己定位为现代政治以及参与现代国家所需的各种技能和价值观的极好学校。所以所有那些关于至高存在的言论，以及所有那些相当模糊——嗯，同时又非常详细，但也有些模糊——的宗教言论，我的感觉是，那是
the Enlightenment. And it's designed for an age where they don't want sectarian passions to sort of, you know, people are arguing all the time about high and low church and Catholic and Protestant and stuff. And this is a good way of smoothing that over. But it's also, it is very Whiggish and very enlightened and very mid-18th century. You can absolutely see why it appealed to the founding fathers
启蒙运动的产物。它是为一个不希望宗派激情引发冲突的时代而设计的。你知道，人们总是在争论高教会派与低教会派、天主教徒和新教徒之类的事情，而这（共济会）是抚平这些分歧的好方法。但同时，它也非常具有辉格党色彩、非常开明、非常符合18世纪中期的特征。你完全可以看出为什么它会吸引美国的开国元勋，
of the United States, for example, can't you? Yeah, no, that's absolutely right. You know, we better come on to the secrets. Am I allowed say the secrets online yeah i can see you're itching to tell okay because you know freemasons swear uh the most terrifying oaths during their rituals to maintain the secrets of freemasonry do we know what these oaths are because presumably they have to keep them secret oh yeah yeah no you can feed oaths are? Because presumably they have to keep them secret. Oh, yeah, yeah. No, you can fiend them online. You know, yes, you've got to keep them secret and it all happens in a secret place
比如说，对吧？是的，没错。你知道的，我们最好还是谈谈秘密。我能说出这些秘密吗？是的，我能看出你已经迫不及待要说了。好吧，因为你知道，共济会员在仪式上会发下最可怕的誓言，以保守共济会的秘密。我们知道这些誓言是什么吗？因为据推测他们必须保守秘密。哦，是的，是的。不，你可以在网上找到它们。你知道，是的，你必须保守秘密，这一切都发生在一个秘密的地方，
and it's all hidden by symbols and stuff like that. But once you strip all of the, you know, the kind of funny walks and oaths and all that out of the way. I love the quote you give of, what was it, Custos, a Portuguese, was he Portuguese? I can't remember he was london based but he was a huguenot yes who gets kind of abducted by the inquisition in portugal and
而且这一切都被符号等东西所掩盖。但一旦你剥离了所有那些，你知道的，古怪的步伐、誓言以及所有诸如此类的事情。我喜欢你引用的那句话，是谁来着，库斯托斯（Custos），一个葡萄牙人——他是葡萄牙人吗？我不记得了。他住在伦敦，但他是胡格诺派（Huguenot）。
tortured and confesses to all kinds of stuff and then comes back and he you think that that basically the secrecy is is just a way of getting people to join. As secrecy naturally excited curiosity, this prompted great numbers of persons to enter into this society. So the secrecy is basically a marketing tool. Among other things, it's a very good marketing tool. But the secrets, once you get three main rituals to really begin your career as a Freemason, the Entered Apprentice, the entered apprentice, the fellow
是的，他在葡萄牙被宗教裁判所绑架并遭受酷刑，招认了各种各样的事情，然后回来了。你认为，基本上，保密只是一种吸引人们加入的手段。“由于保密自然激发了好奇心，这促使大量的人加入了这个社会。”所以保密基本上是一种营销工具。除其他外，它是一个非常好的营销工具。但是这些秘密——一旦你经历了三个主要仪式，从而真正开始你作为共济会员的生涯：学徒（the Entered Apprentice）、
craft, and the master Mason ritual. Once you've been through those, you are a Freemason in the full sense of the word. And each one of those has this terrifying secret that you're supposed to learn. And the first one that you learn in the Entered Apprentice, you know, after all of this palaver of blindfolding and swords pointed at your breasts and all of this kind of stuff, is that you've got to be a nice chap. And the second secret at the end of the fellow craft ritual, again, lots of palaver, is that it's a good idea to find out more about the world and the third secret you can tell i'm not a freemason of course because of course he would say this yeah of course you would yeah we're not falling for that it's probably as good a proof as you're going to get um if if somebody gives away the secrets like this. But you can find them on the internet anywhere you want. Anyway, and the third secret after the Master Mason ritual,
同工（the fellow craft）和共济会大师（master Mason）仪式——一旦你经历了这些，你就是名副其实的共济会员了。而这其中的每一个仪式都有一个你被要求去学习的恐怖秘密。你在学徒阶段学到的第一个秘密——在经历了所有这些蒙上双眼、剑尖直指胸口以及所有诸如此类的手续之后——就是你得当个好人。而在同工仪式结束时学到的第二个秘密，同样经过了许多繁文缛节，就是去更多地了解世界是个好主意。至于第三个秘密——你可以看出我不是共济会员，当然，因为他会这么说——是的，当然会，我们可不会上当。这大概是你所能找到的最好的证据了，如果有人像这样泄露秘密的话。但你可以在互联网上的任何地方找到它们。无论如何，第三个秘密在共济会大师仪式之后——
which is an extraordinary bit of theatre, you know, you're sort of ritually beaten to death by other Freemasons and then sort of zipped into a body bag and carried around the lodge building and then symbolically revived by this sort of Masonic manhug. And the secret you learn at the end of all of this is that death is quite a serious business, and it kind of makes you think a bit. In other words, the secrets are just towering, towering banalities. And that tells us a number
那是一场非同寻常的戏剧，你知道的，你被其他共济会员在仪式上“殴打致死”，然后被拉上拉链装进尸袋，在会所建筑里抬来抬去，接着被这种共济会式的“男人的拥抱”象征性地复活。而你在这一切结束时学到的秘密是：死亡是一件相当严肃的事情，这会让你稍微思考一下。换句话说，这些秘密都是高耸入云、空洞乏味的陈词滥调。这告诉了我们几件事。
of things. One is, that's quite ingenious. Rather than making some terrifying political or theological secret the truth, the secret, they're making it this kind of empty form of secrecy, which is open to everybody. Nobody can disagree with these, whatever religious faith you are and so on and so forth. They're a vehicle of tolerance. But what they do do is borrow the whole kind of aura of secrecy and mystery of secrecy to create a certain sort of quasi-religious feeling around the rituals and around Freemasonry and a sense of sacredness around their rituals while not treading on anybody's toes. And is that why it's so popular with the founding fathers who like that kind of watered down deist kind of approach to things, do you think?
第一，这相当巧妙。与其把某个可怕的政治或神学秘密当作真理或秘密，他们反倒把它做成了一种空洞的保密形式，这对所有人都是开放的。不管你信仰什么宗教，等等，没有人会不同意这些。它们是宽容的载体。但它们确实做到了借用整套保密和神秘的光环，在仪式和共济会周围营造出一种准宗教的情感，在不踩到任何人脚趾的同时，为他们的仪式赋予一种神圣感。这难道就是为什么它在开国元勋中如此受欢迎的原因吗？他们喜欢那种被水化了的自然神论式的处理方式，你觉得呢？
Yes, exactly. I mean, it works very well for them. There were Freemasons on both sides in the American War of Independence. The military is full of Freemasons on both sides. But it's really once they set about setting up the rules of the Republic and Washington's in place that Washington, particularly, who was a Freemason, sees, well, look, we haven't got religion to legitimate what we're doing. And all the lessons of history are that republics don't work. We know that. Wherever you are, particularly in classical history, republic, it's going to collapse into anarchy or tyranny sooner or later. So what we need is something to give us a sense of sacredness without having any particular religious kind of input, without offending anybody. And the
是的，完全正确。我的意思是，这对他们非常有用。在美国独立战争中，双方都有共济会员。军队里到处都是双方的共济会员。但真正关键的是，一旦他们着手建立共和国的规则，华盛顿上台后，华盛顿——特别是华盛顿本人就是一个共济会员——他看到：好吧，我们没有宗教来为我们的所作所为赋予合法性。而所有的历史教训都表明，共和国是行不通的。我们知道这一点。无论你在哪里，尤其是在古典历史中，共和国迟早会崩溃为无政府状态或暴政。所以我们需要的是某种东西，在没有任何特定宗教介入、不冒犯任何人的前提下，赋予我们一种神圣感。而
Freemasons are perfectly fitted for that task. So that's why Washington is very public about his Freemasonry when he's president and why he, for example, in the laying of the cornerstone of the Capitol building in Washington, it's a ceremony I kind of reconstruct in the book, you know, this is, you know, Washington, he knows this city is going to carry his name. He knows that it's going to have a big statue of him at the center. And, you know, at the moment, it's just a have a big statue of him at the center. And at the moment, it's just a plan drawn out in the mud on the banks of the Potomac. And yet he uses a Masonic ceremony, and the Masons are very good at ceremonies and rituals and all that stuff, to give this sense of sacredness. Here we're founding something really important.
共济会员完美地契合了这一任务。这就是为什么华盛顿在担任总统时毫不掩饰他的共济会员身份，为什么他在华盛顿特区国会大厦奠基仪式上——这是一个我在书中重构的仪式，你知道的，华盛顿很清楚这座城市将以他的名字命名，他知道中心将竖起他的巨型雕像，而且，当时这只是波托马克河岸泥地里画出的一张蓝图。尽管如此，他还是使用了共济会仪式——共济会员非常擅长仪式、典礼和所有这些东西——来赋予这种神圣感：在这里，我们正在奠定某种真正重要的东西。
And when reports of that reach around the country, it really sets off this fashion for Freemasonry and for Masonic cornerstone laying ceremonies in the early American Republic. And what about the dollar bill? So that's something that comes up. If you spend any time on social media, that's something that comes up on if you spend any time on social media that kind of thing comes up again and again that you know it's part
当这些报道传遍全国时，它确实在早期美利坚共和国掀起了一股对共济会和共济会奠基仪式的狂热。那么美元纸币呢？所以这是另一个会出现的话题。如果你花时间刷社交媒体，这也是如果你花时间刷社交媒体时会不断出现的话题，你知道的，这是全球主义阴谋的一部分，而且从一开始就是这样，那个眼睛——叫什么来着？上帝之眼（the eye of providence）还是别的什么名字，我不记得它叫什么了，你知道的，金字塔、所有这些东西——这其中真的有共济会的长期影响在起作用吗？是的，还有什么比他们把它印在美元纸币上宣传更好的全球阴谋证据呢？不，其实并不是。最初那个象征符号——带有全视之眼的金字塔——在某个时期曾是国玺的反面，那大概是在1780年代的某个时候。那是1790年代早期被确立下来的。但在当时，它并不是一个共济会的符号。
of a globalist conspiracy and has been from the beginning the eye what is it the eye of providence or whatever it's called i can't remember what it's called you know the pyramid all that stuff is the genuine sort of masonic influence going on there yeah what better evidence do you need of a global conspiracy than the fact they're advertising it on the dollar bill no that didn't it was originally that symbol the pyramid with the all-seeing eye uh was at some point the obverse of the seal of state uh and that was i forget in the 1780s sometime. That was early 1790s was kind of put in place. But at the time, it wasn't a Masonic symbol.
据我们所知，设计它的所有人里没有一个是共济会员。不，它是在30年代罗斯福（FDR）执政期间被合并到美元纸币上的。当时有人提议使用这种新设计的美元，作为设计的一部分，它复活了（如果你愿意这样说的话）国玺的反面。罗斯福非常担心这会冒犯他的天主教支持者基础，因为在这个时候，共济会员一直在到处搜罗各种符号——没有什么比符号更受共济会员喜爱了，他们会从任何地方收集符号——因此这也造成了关于他们起源的混乱，因为圣殿骑士团、古埃及，这些都能带来好的仪式。所以他实际上是想核实一下，如果他在美元纸币上印上某种可能被某些人解释为
And as far as we know, none of the people who designed it were Freemasons. No, it gets incorporated onto the dollar bill under FDR in the 30s. And FDR, when using this new design for the dollar was proposed, which resurrected, if you like, this obverse of the seal of state as part of the design of the dollar bill. really worried that that would kind of offend his catholic base because by this time the freemasons who have been hoovering up symbols left right and center nothing masons like more than than symbols and there will get them from anywhere um hence the confusion about their origins because the templars you know ancient egypt it's good. It all makes for good ceremonies. So he wanted to actually check that his Catholic base wouldn't be offended if he put a sort of what some might interpret
共济会符号的图案，他的天主教支持者基础是否会因此感到被冒犯，而他得到的答复是请放宽心。不幸的是，他当时无法预知后来围绕它滋生出的种种阴谋论。在一张纸币上，而他得到了保证。不幸的是，他无法预知后来围绕它滋生出的种种阴谋论。好吧，说到阴谋论和天主教对共济会的厌恶——我们在本期节目开篇时就提到了这一点——我认为我们应该在下半场讨论这个话题，探讨共济会在法国大革命中据称发挥的作用，以及它在19世纪法国天主教与世俗舆论极化过程中确实发挥的作用。所以我们休息之后会回来继续讨论这个话题。
as a Masonic symbol on the dollar bill, and he was reassured. Unfortunately, he wasn't to know about the conspiracy theories that would grow up around it much later. a bill and he was reassured. Unfortunately, he wasn't to know about the conspiracy theories that would grow up around it much later. Well, so talking of conspiracy theories and Catholic dislike of Freemasonry, which we opened the episode with, we should come to that, I think, in the second half, look at the role that Freemasonry is supposed to have played in the French Revolution and the role it definitely plays in kind of polarising Catholic and secular opinion in France in the 19th century. So we will come back and talk about that after the break.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及少许秀场八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告音频、加更节目并抢先获得现场门票，
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
请前往 therestisentternment.com。网址是 therestisentternment.com。你知道吗，多米尼克，我本来想尝试演唱夜后（Queen of the Night）的咏叹调，对吧，来自莫扎特的歌剧《魔笛》。我搜集到了一些资料——约翰，也许你可以证实这个猜想——这首歌剧是关于共济会仪式的，它有点像是莫扎特版本的共济会仪式，你懂的。
head to therestisentertainment.com That's therestisentertainment.com Do you know Dominic I was going to try and do the aria of the queen of the night yes um from mozart's opera the magic flute which uh i gather john maybe you could confirm this supposition is about a masonic rituals it's kind of mozart's version of the rituals that you go through
无论如何，我的嗓子唱不了夜后的咏叹调。顺便说一句，如果我们有任何听众想要截取这段音频，把它当成一个小剪辑发到社交媒体上，我是不会阻止他们的。是的，我对这部作品的解读是，莫扎特就像他的好友海顿一样——海顿也是个共济会员——共济会绝对影响了《魔笛》。但作为一名优秀的共济会员，他是不会泄露共济会秘密的。所以他创作出来的是一种非常强烈、非常具有辨识度的共济会风味，同时又为自己保留了一点否认的余地。
anyway my voice isn't up to singing the Hour of the Queen of the Night. If any of our listeners, by the way, want to excerpt that, put it as a little clip on social media, I'm not going to stop them. Yeah, my reading of that is that Mozart was like his mate Haydn, Haydn was a Freemason, and he definitely Freemasonry influenced the Magic Flute. But being a good Freemason, he wasn't going to give away the Masonic secret. So what he produces is a sort of very strong, very recognisable Masonic flavour while giving him sort of a bit of deniability about it.
就在我们讨论法国大革命之前——我知道汤姆说过我们在中场休息前要谈论这个——对于所有那些人，乔治·华盛顿、莫扎特，所有这些18世纪的人来说，我的理解是否正确：对他们而言，加入共济会有趣，有各种仪式，对所有人开放，包容且开明。
Just before we come to the French Revolution, which I know Tom said we were going to talk about just before the break, for all those people, George Washington, Mozart, all these people in the 18th century, am I right in thinking that for them, joining the Masons is, you know, it's fun, there's the rituals, it's open to everybody, it's tolerant, it's kind of enlightened.
这有点像如果你是个潮人，今天去加入一个私人会员俱乐部。这里面有一点真相吗？它确实很酷，你能遇到很多有趣的人，但并没有什么重大的——你知道的——并没有什么形而上学的重要意义，成为共济会员对你来说不是一件关乎存在主义的大事？还是说我把它说得太轻描淡写了？嗯，我想你确实稍微有点低估了。
It's a bit like joining a private members club today if you're a kind of hipster. Is there a bit of truth in that, that it's kind of enlightened it's a bit like joining a private members club today if you're a kind of hipster is it is there a bit of truth in that that it's kind of cool and you meet lots of interesting people but there's no great you know there's no metaphysical importance to you necessarily it's not an existential thing to be a mason or am i underplaying it um i think you are underplaying it a little bit i, you have to remember that people join Freemasonry for lots of different reasons, and it means different things to different people. In the same way that the secrets are a kind of empty center that then lead people to imagine and project all sorts of things onto them, whether they're Masons or non-Masons,
你必须记住，人们出于各种不同的原因加入共济会，它对不同的人意味着不同的事情。就像秘密是一个空洞的核心，进而引导人们去想象并将各种事情投射到它们身上一样，无论他们是共济会员还是非共济会员，
there are different ways of living out your Freemasonry. Certainly 18th century, you know, it felt very modern and temporary. It's also about status. You know, there's lots of badges and stages to go through. And, you know, as Freemasonry went on, they invented, you know, they didn't just have, there were just two degrees when Freemasonry went on, they invented, you know, they didn't just have, there were just two degrees when Freemasonry started off. Then they added another one. And then this growth became kind of exponential. And that, because people love the badges of status, the kind of the outside world, but is a kind of refracted version of it. So there's all sorts of aspects. But in cases, it kind of erases status, doesn't it? Because the gloves that Masons wear are designed to ensure that you can't know whether you're shaking the hand of a duke or a dustman, I read in your book. Yeah, that's the conventional explanation within Freemasonry. Certainly, there's a sort of
都有不同的方式来践行你的共济会生活。当然，在18世纪，它感觉非常现代和具有临时性。这也关乎身份地位。你知道的，有很多徽章和要经历的阶段。而且，随着共济会的发展，他们发明了——共济会刚开始时只有两个等级。然后他们又增加了一个。接着这种增长就呈指数级爆发了。而且，因为人们喜爱身份地位的徽章，外部世界也是它的一种折射版本。所以有各种各样的方面。但在某些情况下，它确实消除了阶层地位，不是吗？因为共济会员佩戴的手套旨在确保你无法分辨自己握住的是公爵的手还是清洁工的手，我在你的书中读到了这一点。是的，那是共济会内部对它的传统解释。当然，这里有一种
utopian, egalitarian vibe. The idea of brotherhood, you know, if I'm an ordinary member of a lodge, and so is, you know, the Duke of Kent, in theory, we are just brothers, you know, we are equal, formally equal. And that's very exciting. That sort of temporary suspension of the rules of the outside world. So liberty, equality, and fraternity. And so you could, I guess, see why in 1797, a Catholic abbé wrote about the revolution that everything in the French Revolution, everything right down to the most appalling deeds was foreseen, premeditated, arranged, resolved upon and decided. Everything was caused by the deepest wickedness because everything was prepared and directed by men who alone held the thread uniting the intrigues that had long been
乌托邦式的、平等主义的氛围。你知道，兄弟会的理念，如果我是一个会所的普通成员，肯特公爵也是，那在理论上，我们就是兄弟，我们是平等的，形式上的平等。这非常令人兴奋。那种对外部世界规则的暂时中止。所以是自由、平等、博爱。所以，我想你可以理解，为什么在1797年，一位天主教神甫在谈到革命时会写下，法国大革命中的一切，乃至最骇人听闻的行径，都是被预见、预谋、安排、决定和裁决的。一切都源于最深重的邪恶，因为一切都是由那些独自掌握着将长期交织在秘密社会内部的阴谋串联起来的线索的人所筹备和导演的。
woven within the secret society. So the idea that these principles that the French Revolution flaunt are actually deriving from Freemasonry, and it's all a kind of scam and is a veil covering what is in fact deep wickedness. And this is a Catholic theme that runs right the way through the 19th century, and it's what Leo Taxil is basically exploiting. Yes, absolutely right. I mean, we owe the birth of the conspiracy theory in its modern form, the idea of the secret elite behind the scenes controlling everything. That fantasy we owe to Catholic fear of Freemasonry,
因此，法国大革命所炫耀的这些原则实际上源于共济会，这完全是一个骗局，是一层掩盖其事实上深重邪恶的面纱。这是一个贯穿整个19世纪的天主教主题，而这也正是莱奥·塔克西尔基本上在利用的东西。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，现代形式的阴谋论的诞生——即幕后存在一个控制一切的秘密精英集团的想法——我们要归功于天主教对共济会的恐惧，
the idea that somehow it's just a front, that there's some demonic purpose behind it, that fear, which is systematized, as you said, by this guy, the Abbe Barwell, who's sitting in his house on the Edgware Road in London in exile from the French Revolution, trying to make sense of the consternation caused by the French Revolution, the overthrowing of throne and altar, it's got to be a conspiracy. Somebody's got to be to blame, and it's got to be the Freemasons, who the Pope had excommunicated as long ago as 1738. And that idea becomes very, very contagious. And the Freemasons are perfect for it, because they've got this sort of Russian doll. Firstly, they've got their code of secrecy,
这种认为它只是一种掩护、背后有着某种恶魔般目的的想法，这种恐惧被你刚才提到的人——巴鲁埃尔神甫系统化了。他当时正流亡伦敦，住在埃奇韦尔路的家中，躲避着法国大革命，试图去理清法国大革命、王权和圣坛的推翻所带来的惊恐。这一定是一个阴谋。总得有人来承担责任，而这个人一定就是共济会。教皇早在1738年就已经将他们逐出了教会。这个想法变得极具传染性。而共济会对此再合适不过了，因为他们有着这种俄罗斯套娃般的结构。首先，他们有保密法则，
you know, and they may well say, oh, no, honestly, there's really nothing to it. They would say that, wouldn't they? And then even their structure lends itself to this, this Russian doll thing of, you know, ever higher degrees. And the myth that was created was that this was all kind of machinery for depriving people of their free will until they became sort of Satanist robots by the time they got to the high... Guillotining everyone. Yes, exactly. By the time of the higher degrees. And it was all aimed at overthrowing throne and altar, bringing about exactly what happened under the Jacobins.
你知道，他们很可能会说，哦，不，老实说，这真的没什么大不了的。他们当然会这么说，不是吗？而且甚至他们的结构也很符合这种俄罗斯套娃式的层层递进的高阶学位。当时创造的神话是，这一切都是某种剥夺人们自由意志的机器，直到他们进入高阶时，变成某种撒旦主义的机器人……把所有人都送上断头台。是的，完全正确。到了高阶学位的时候。而这一切的目的都是为了推翻王权和圣坛，带来雅各宾派统治下那种完全一致的后果。
But there's a tiny degree of... So in the first half, we were talking about how Freemasonry was identified with wiggery, with Enlightenment principles, with tolerance, with free thinking, with brotherhood, erasing distinctions underneath the gloves, whatever. So when the Abbe Baruel says, oh, well, this is all a result of Freemasonry, there's a pitiful, minuscule little germ of sense there, is there? Yeah, I think so.
但这里面有一点点的……所以在前半部分，我们讨论了共济会如何被等同于辉格党人、启蒙运动原则、宽容、自由思想、兄弟会，消除手套之下的差异等等。因此，当巴鲁埃尔神甫说，哦，这一切都是共济会的结果时，这里面是不是有一点可怜的、微乎其微的道理呢？是的，我想是的。
I mean, even if you take Freemasonry at face value, you know, for what it is in the 18th century, it looks deeply, deeply dodgy. You know, it's a centre of aggregation away from the court, away from, you know, free thinking. So it's subversive and heretical. And therefore, even in the most innocent interpretation of it for the church is positively dangerous. Does the Catholic Church have a sense of it as being from Britain, being in that sense, Protestant or not? Yeah, I think so. I mean, it's also, it would soon become associated with Judaism and all sorts of, you know, anything and everything that they didn't like. I think primarily for them, it's heretical. Because what happens is the Freemason, and it has its roots in all of the most ancient heresies, you know, the Man has its roots in all of the most ancient heresies,
我的意思是，即使你按字面意思来看待共济会，也就是它在18世纪本来的样子，它看起来也极其、极其可疑。你知道，这是一个远离法庭的聚合中心，远离那种自由思考的地方。所以它是颠覆性的、异端的。因此，即便是站在教会最无辜的解释角度，它也绝对是危险的。天主教会有没有意识到它来自英国，从这个意义上说是新教的还是别的什么？是的，我想是的。我的意思是，它很快也会与犹太教以及各种他们不喜欢的东西联系在一起。我认为对他们来说，最主要的还是它是异端的。因为发生的事情是，共济会，它根源于所有最古老的异端邪说，你知道，摩尼教徒根源于所有最古老的异端邪说，
you know, the Manichaeans and all of these people. So basically they're buying into what the Freemasons are saying. I mean, are they thinking that it comes from Babylon and from… Yeah, that's exactly it. The Templars or whatever, you know, who, as we all know, ended up rather badly. That's the point. The Freemasons have gone round during the 18th
你知道，摩尼教徒和所有这些人。所以基本上他们是在接受共济会员们的说法。我是说，他们认为它来自巴比伦和……对，就是这样。圣殿骑士团什么的，正如我们所知，最后结局相当糟糕。关键就在这里。共济会在整个18世纪到处搜集这些庞大的符号博物馆、符号陈列柜，
century assembling these vast sort of museum of symbols, display cases of symbols that they can use to say, you know, to show that they're very ancient and they go back to the Old Testament or whatever it is, and they've given them all these symbols for the sort of mise-en-scene of their ritual performances. And all the Abbé Barwell and those who followed him had to do would say, well, Manichaeanists, clearly, you know, heresy, you know, the Templars, good grief, devil worshippers, Baphomet. So they take the irony of this, of course, they take the Mason's version of their own history at face value and just, you know. Yeah, because we did some various episodes on the Cathars and how essentially the notion of Catharism was invented in the 19th century by nervous Catholic writers. And I guess that this is all part of that swirl and mix. But meanwhile, while all this palaver is going on in France, in the British Empire, it does seem to be playing a role slightly analogous to cricket.
他们可以用这些符号来表明他们历史悠久，可以追溯到旧约等等，他们把所有这些符号都用在了他们仪式表演的布景中。而巴鲁埃尔神甫以及那些追随他的人所要做的，就是说，看吧，摩尼教徒，显然是异端；圣殿骑士团，天哪，魔鬼崇拜者，巴风特。所以他们讽刺地全盘接受了共济会对自己历史的说法，并直接……是的，因为我们之前做过一些关于卡特派的节目，以及卡特派的概念本质上是如何在19世纪被神经质的天主教作家发明的。我想这也是那种混乱和交融的一部分。但与此同时，当所有这些废话在法国上演时，在大英帝国，它似乎确实在起着一种类似于板球的作用。
So we mentioned this before, but it is being taken out, say, to India. And just as Indians start to play cricket and it becomes a game where Indians and British can meet on the playing field. So in India, the whole idea of brotherhood and the erasure of race and religion and things like that means that these lodges become places where British and Indians can meet and become Masons. Is that right? Meet on the level in Masonic jargon. Yeah, that's absolutely right. I mean, Fre masonry does so much work for the british empire um for a start it's a kind of welfare system for imperials and
所以我们之前提到过这一点，但它正被带到印度去。正如印度人开始打板球，并使之成为印度人和英国人可以在球场上相遇的一项运动一样。因此在印度，兄弟会以及消除种族、宗教等界限的整个理念意味着，这些会所成了英国人和印度人可以相遇并成为共济会员的地方。是这样吗？在共济会的术语中叫“在同一水平线上相遇”。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，共济会为大英帝国做了大量的工作，首先，它是一种帝国人员的福利系统，
a social network you can be if you're an imperial soldier particularly or a sailor or if you're uh you know a bureaucrat or a merchant, whatever it is, you can find a kind of home from home, the familiar. You can find a welcome. Your Masonic credentials are your passport to a world of mutual support and a social life and a bit of fun and so on and so forth. So that is very important. But then you're absolutely right.
一个社交网络。如果你是一名帝国士兵，尤其是水手，或者如果你是一个官僚、商人，无论是什么，你都能找到一种宾至如归、熟悉的感觉。你能找到一个受欢迎的地方。你的共济会资历就是你通往相互支持、社交生活以及一点乐趣等的世界的通行证。所以这非常重要。但随后你是对的，
There is this element of kind of allowing the native elites a bit of conditioned access. You can check them beforehand, check they're okay. But particularly if they're politically useful, like whatever various members of the Indian elite are, you can bring them on board and flatter them and, you know, flatter them with this sort of formalized equality that you get on the playing field or indeed in the Masonic Lodge. You have this brilliant stat, and I'm quoting from your wonderful book,
这里确实有一种允许本土精英进行某种有条件的准入的元素。你可以事先审查他们，确保他们没问题。但特别是如果他们在政治上有用的话，比如印度精英的各种成员，你可以把他们吸收进来，奉承他们，用这种你在球场上或共济会会所里得到的形式上的平等来奉承他们。你有一个精彩的数据，我引用你那本精彩的书中的话：
by the outbreak of the First World War, there were at least 10 brothers in India who put Maharaja in the occupation column of the lodge register. And Kipling said the man who would be king starts with a, there's a whole section about masonry there, isn't there?
到第一次世界大战爆发时，印度至少有10位兄弟在会所名册的职业栏里填上了“大君”。吉卜林说过“想成为国王的人”是从一个……那里有一整段关于共济会的章节，对吧？
Brother this, brother that, they're all kind of shaking hands and giving each other the wink and stuff. Yeah, yeah. I mean, the two rascals are at the center of the man who would be king kind of are freemasons and use masonic rituals to create a bit of woo-woo kind of authority around their their reign and kipling of course you know arch imperialist and the great poet and writer of imperial Freemasonry. And the hatred, going back to Tom's point about the hatred,
这个兄弟，那个兄弟，他们都在握手、递眼色之类的。是的，是的。我的意思是，《想成为国王的人》的核心的那两个恶棍就是共济会员，并利用共济会的仪式在他们的统治周围营造一种神秘主义的权威。当然，吉卜林，你知道，他是超级帝国主义者，是帝国共济会的伟大诗人作家。而那种仇恨，回到汤姆关于仇恨的观点，
the anti-Masonic conspiracy theories, I mean, they are extraordinarily long-lived within Catholic societies, aren't they? So, I mean, one thing that I've always found absolutely mystifying is that Franco, so after the Spanish Civil War, or during the Spanish Civil War, or during the Spanish Civil War, Franco is completely obsessed with Masons. And there's all kinds of- Well, he got blackballed, didn't he? Well, there's all kinds of anti-Masonic legislation, isn't there? I mean, really virulent,
反共济会的阴谋论，我的意思是，它们在天主教社会中存在的时间异常长久，不是吗？所以，我一直觉得非常神秘的一件事是，弗朗哥——在西班牙内战之后，或者在西班牙内战期间——弗朗哥对共济会员完全着迷。有各种各样的……好吧，他被投票排斥了，不是吗？嗯，有各种各样的反共济会立法，不是吗？非常恶毒的，
are there that many Masons in Spain? Wasn't he blackballed by his own brother? Yeah, that's the theory. We don't know. And his brother who later disappeared in a suspicious plane crash. But let's not go down that rabbit hole. Yeah, I mean, there's a lot said about, you know, the Masons themselves love to talk about their martyrs, if you like, and they love to tell stories of their oppression and how the world has misunderstood them. And the key baddies in their narratives are the Nazis, who did indeed ban Freemasonry in 1935. But actually, much, much worse than Hitler when it came to clamping down on Freemasonry was Franco, as you say. I mean, the Spanish military at the time, and anybody from a Catholic background in Spain at the time, and imbibed very, very profound hatred and suspicion of Freemasonry. You know, the culture wars that we saw in 19th century Catholic Europe that led to that taxil hoax, you know, the sort of free-thinking taxil taking the mick out of the church's obsession with Freemasonry, were
西班牙真的有那么多共济会员吗？他不是被他自己的亲兄弟排斥了吗？是的，这是个理论。我们不知道。还有他的兄弟后来在一次可疑的飞机坠毁中失踪了。但我们还是别钻那个牛角尖了。是的，我的意思是，有很多关于……你知道，共济会员自己喜欢谈论他们的烈士，如果你愿意的话，他们喜欢讲述他们遭受迫害以及世界如何误解他们的故事。他们叙事中的关键坏蛋是纳粹，纳粹确实在1935年取缔了共济会。但事实上，在镇压共济会方面，弗朗哥比希特勒糟糕得多，正如你所说。我的意思是，当时西班牙的军方，以及当时西班牙任何天主教背景的人，都潜移默化地吸收了对共济会非常非常深切的仇恨和怀疑。你知道，我们在19世纪天主教欧洲看到的文化战争导致了那个塔克西尔骗局，（自由思想的塔克西尔取笑教会对共济会的痴迷），在西班牙尤其恶毒。
particularly virulent in Spain. And that Catholic anti-Masonry is really the reason why Franco was much more brutal in repressing Freemasons than were either Mussolini or Hitler, who both all the same did abolish Freemasonry. Yeah, Franco, I mean, was fed information for a long time by this group, a sort of secret network that uh claimed to be you know from some deep throat inside the international masonic conspiracy and this goes on from pretty much the end of the spanish civil war right until the mid-60s i think uh and they're telling me yeah they're out to get you and you know you know, when Truman becomes... And who were they?
而这种天主教的反共济会主义，确实是弗朗哥比墨索里尼或希特勒（尽管他们也都取缔了共济会）更残酷地镇压共济会员的原因。是的，弗朗哥，我的意思是，很长一段时间里，情报都是由这个组织喂给他的。这是一个秘密网络，声称自己来自国际共济会阴谋内部的某种深喉。这种情况从西班牙内战结束一直持续到60年代中期，我想，他们告诉他，是的，他们要来抓你了。你知道，当杜鲁门成为……他们是谁？
Well, we don't really know who was behind this. I mean, it was all completely fake information. They'd been making up, you know, bulletins from Masonic Central Command internationally and, you know, letters from Truman or whoever it might be, or Roosevelt and Churchill, making all this intelligence up to feed Franco's paranoia. And the best guess is that they were just using it to kind of get at enemies within the regime.
好吧，我们并不真正知道谁是幕后黑手。我的意思是，这完全是假情报。他们一直在捏造国际共济会中央指挥部的公告，以及杜鲁门、罗斯福或丘吉尔等人的信件，捏造所有这些情报来喂养弗朗哥的偏执。最好的猜测是，他们只是用它来打击政权内部的敌人。
But Franco also set up this special tribunal to repress, to put Freemasons on trial. I mean, minimum sentence sentence 12 years for membership of freemasonry or indeed of you know any of the masonic supposed masonic front organizations like the rotary club or the rotary club yeah you're speaking esperanto or any anything like that made you a freemason and in the the end, although, you know, there were at most 1,000 former Freemasons left in Spain at the time, there were 80,000 Freemasons listed. And you can still visit, I've visited the kind of archives in Salamanca where they have all these paranoid records of Franco's regime.
但弗朗哥还成立了这个特别法庭来镇压、审判共济会员。我的意思是，加入共济会或共济会的任何所谓外围组织（如扶轮社）的最低刑期是12年。扶轮社，是的，你说世界语或任何类似的东西都会让你成为共济会员。最终，尽管当时西班牙最多只剩下1000名前共济会员，但名单上却有80000名共济会员。你现在仍然可以参观——我参观过萨拉曼卡的档案馆，那里保存着弗朗哥政权所有这些偏执的记录。
And there's a terrible museum, isn't there, with awful waxworks in Salamanca? Yeah, that's right. Because, of course, like all of these authoritarian regimes, they claimed that they finally, finally, finally were able to expose the secrets of Freemasonry. And so when they raided and closed down the lodges, they kind of pinched the best bits of kit from the lodges filled up these showcase propaganda lodges with all this material uh with sort of dummies in cloaks and and things like that and said oh you see you know demonic conspiracy that's what they're at and they made great um uh visitor exhibits it's not difficult to make freemasonry look kind of macabre and weird
萨拉曼卡还有一个可怕的博物馆，里面有可怕的蜡像，对吧？是的，没错。因为当然，像所有这些独裁政权一样，他们声称他们终于、终于、终于能够揭露共济会的秘密了。所以当他们突袭并关闭会所时，他们顺走了会所里最好的装备，用所有这些材料——带着斗篷的假人等等——填满了这些展示用的宣传会所，并说，哦，你看，这就是魔鬼阴谋，这就是他们在搞的鬼。他们把这些做成了极好的游客展览。让人觉得共济会阴谋诡谲、怪异并不难，
because a lot of the rituals have kind of death and skulls and coffins and all of that sort of stuff in. So that's Spain. What about Italy? Because, of course, in Italy, I mean, you've written about the mafia, particularly in the 1970s with the P2 Lodge, which is this sort of ultra right-wing breakaway lodge that's in, if you read any sort of slightly conspiracy theory book about 70s,
因为许多仪式中都有死亡、骷髅、棺材以及所有这类东西。所以那是西班牙。意大利呢？因为当然，在意大利，我的意思是，你写过关于黑手党的内容，特别是20世纪70年代的P2（Propaganda Due）会所，这是一个极右翼的分裂会所。如果你读任何关于70年代、
80s Italy, P2 are controlling everything. They're involved with the Vatican Bank, the death of Roberto Calvi, who's hanging. Where is he hanging from? A bridge? Blackfriars Bridge, isn't he? So he was a banker working for the Vatican, God's banker. God's banker. Wasn't he God's banker? Yes, that's right? So he was a banker working for the Vatican. God's banker. God's banker.
80年代意大利的略带阴谋论的书籍，P2都在控制一切。他们与梵蒂冈银行有关联，与罗伯托·卡尔维的死有关，他被吊着。他被吊在哪里？一座桥上？黑衣修士桥，对吧？所以他是一个为梵蒂冈工作的银行家，上帝的银行家。上帝的银行家。他难道不是上帝的银行家吗？是的，没错。所以他是一个为梵蒂冈工作的银行家。上帝的银行家。上帝的银行家。
Wasn't he God's banker? Yes, that's right. And he was a member of P2. Is that true? Yeah. I mean, this is where, you know, this is really where the most, perhaps not Satanist, but the most outlandish conspiracy theories actually proved to be true.
他难道不是上帝的银行家吗？是的，没错。他是P2的成员。真的吗？是的。我的意思是，这正是——也许不是撒旦主义，但最离奇的阴谋论实际上被证明是真的地方。
The P2 is a kind of limit case of real conspiracy. And what happened basically is this guy, Licio Gelli, who was a former fascist, basically. Freemasonry is in deep trouble in Italy in the post-war period because both of the dominant political parties, the Communist Party and the Christian Democrats, are both anti-Masonic. They both won't let Freemasons join them. There's an article in the new Italian Constitution that bans secret societies without explicitly mentioning the Freemasons. So the Freemasons are worried, and they really want to get back to their glory days in the 19th century when they were very influential in Italy.
P2是真实阴谋的一个极限案例。基本上发生的事情是，这个名叫利乔·杰利的家伙，基本上是个前法西斯分子。战后时期，意大利的共济会陷入了极大的麻烦，因为两个占主导地位的政党——共产党和基督教民主党——都是反共济会的。他们都不允许共济会员加入。意大利新宪法中有一条规定，在没有明确提及共济会的情况下取缔秘密结社。所以共济会员们很担心，他们非常渴望回到19世纪他们在意大利极具影响力的黄金时代。
And this guy, Licio Gelli, comes along and says, look, you know, I've got loads of really important friends. And I can make sure they come into Freemasonry and we can do something really, you know, like back in the old days. Because back in the old days, all the elite Freemasons in Italy belonged to this lodge called Lodge Propaganda, which was right under the control of the Grand Master of the Grand Orient of Italy, almost his personal lodge. So they weren't bothered by ordinary Freemasons asking them for favours or, you know, selfies or whatever they did back in those days. And Gelli eventually took control of this, re-engineered it, and turned it into his personal
而这个叫利乔·杰利的家伙出现了，他说，听着，我有大量非常重要的高层朋友。我可以确保他们加入共济会，我们可以做点真正像过去那样的事情。因为在过去，意大利所有的精英共济会员都属于一个叫做“宣传”的会所，它直接受意大利大东方总大师的控制，几乎是他个人的会所。所以他们不用烦恼普通共济会员向他们索要恩惠或自拍照什么的。杰利最终控制了这个会所，对其进行了重新设计，将其变成了他个人的
kind of patronage and blackmail engine, which he uh you know that whole series of scandals where he brought corrupt people together and so how did the vatican and calvi fit into all this well calvi was at the time uh in in an unconnected development the. The church was looking to get money to fund its anti-communist activities in Eastern Europe, you know, Pope John Paul and all that. And so Vatican money was going in and also mafia money and all mingling around in these dodgy banks, which were really the center of the P2 system. And they were the sort of financial lung of what Jelly did. They allowed him to offer, you know, offer to lend money on mates rates terms to troubled businesses in return for them joining and lending support and building the empire.
赞助和勒索机器。他通过一系列丑闻，将腐败分子聚集在一起……那么梵蒂冈和卡尔维是怎么卷入这一切的呢？好吧，卡尔维当时在一个毫不相干的发展中……教会当时正寻求资金来资助其在东欧的反共活动，教皇约翰·保罗等等。所以梵蒂冈的资金进去了，黑手党的资金也进去了，全都在这些可疑的银行里混杂在一起，而这些银行正是P2系统的核心。它们可以说是杰利所作所为的资金肺。它们让他能够以友好利率向陷入困境的企业提供贷款，作为回报，这些企业要加入并提供支持，从而建立他的帝国。
I mean, a lot of Gelli's power was based on bullshit, basically. You know, there's a story, I don't know whether it's true or not, but it ought to be true, is a guy called Alighiero Noschese, who was the sort of Mike Yarwood of Italy of the time. He was the great impersonator. Like you, Tom. Yes, exactly. And he was found to be a member of P2, although he died before it was discovered.
我的意思是，杰利的很多权力基本上都是建立在胡扯的基础上的。你知道，有个故事——我不知道它是真是假，但它理应是真的——有个叫阿尔吉耶罗·诺斯凯泽的家伙，他当时可以说是意大利的迈克·亚伍德。他是伟大的模仿大师。就像你一样，汤姆。是的，完全没错。人们发现他是P2的成员，尽管他在被发现之前就去世了。
And the theory is that when a potential member would come in, Gelli would get this guy to call and put him on speakerphone, and Noschese would pretend to be, I don't know, Giulio Andreotti, would come in, Gelli would get this guy to call and put him on speakerphone, and Noskezi would pretend to be, I don't know, Giulio Andreotti or the interior minister or somebody really well, and say, oh, Giulio, my mate, you know, what can I do for you? And all this kind of thing. Well, here's a scam for us.
而理论是，当潜在成员进来时，杰利会叫这个人打电话并将其置于免提状态，然后诺斯凯泽会假装是，我不知道，朱利奥·安德烈奥蒂，——杰利会叫这个人打电话并将其置于免提状态，然后诺斯凯泽会假装是，我不知道，朱利奥·安德烈奥蒂或内政部长或者某个真正的重要人物，然后说：“哦，朱利奥，我的老朋友，你知道，我能为你做什么？”诸如此类的话。好了，这里有个骗局给我们。
Exactly. But if that story's not true, and it probably isn't, I'm afraid it gives some idea of how you know generally love to boast about all his contacts because of course that attracted more influential contacts into his network and that all came apart in the late 70s 30s is that right it was all exposed when the best particular bank collapsed. Calvi was found, who was handling the money, was found hanged in London. Yeah. Hanged, probably hanged by the Mafia, not by the Freemasons.
确实。但如果这个故事不是真的，恐怕它确实反映了杰利如何喜欢吹嘘他所有的联系人，因为这当然会吸引更多有影响力的联系人在他的网络中。这一切在70年代末30年代瓦解了，是这样吗？当那个特定的银行倒闭时，这一切都暴露了。负责处理资金的卡尔维被发现吊死在伦敦。是的。吊死，可能是被黑手党吊死的，而不是被共济会员。
We still don't know. I mean, you know, it seems to be the most likely explanation that the Mafia were a bit angry because all their money had gone up the spout. Right. But we don't know but we don't know we don't know um but yeah it was 1981 i think it was that the raid discovered the membership lists and lots of other compromising material in his uh office in arezzo in tuscany should we end on a slightly more wholesome note because obviously we don't want to give the impression that freemasons are actually all involved in conspiracy and people hanging in bridges and things so i thought one of the um sweetest things in your book was the discovery that not only had buzz aldrin being a freemason
我们仍然不知道。我的意思是，最可能的解释似乎是黑手党有点生气，因为他们所有的钱都打了水漂。对。但我们不知道，但我们不知道，我们不知道……不过，是的，那是1981年，突袭行动在他在托斯卡纳阿雷佐的办公室里发现了会员名单和大量其他妥协材料。我们是否应该以一个稍微更健康的基调结束？因为显然我们不想给人留下共济会员实际上都参与阴谋和人们在桥上被吊死之类事情的印象。所以我想你书中“最甜蜜”的事情之一，就是发现奥尔德林不仅是个共济会员，
but that he um he'd got special permission from the grand lodge of texas to set up a lodge on the moon yes so yeah yeah tranquility lodge tranquility lodge on the moon. Yes. So, Tranquility Lodge. Tranquility Lodge on the moon, exactly. It's still there if you care to visit, I'm sure. But if the Chinese get to the moon, they won't want to go there, will they? Because it's illegal in China. Yeah, they'll have to stay well clear. But also, there are lots of implausible people.
而且他还从德克萨斯总会所获得了特别许可，在月球上建立了一个会所。是的，没错，宁静会所。月球上的宁静会所。是的，所以，宁静会所。月球上的宁静会所，完全正确。如果你有兴趣去参观的话，它还在那里，我敢肯定。但如果中国人登月了，他们不会想去那里的，对吧？因为这在中国是非法的。是的，他们得离得远远的。而且，还有很多意想不到的人。
I mean, American basketball players and things. Shaquille O'Neal. Clive Lloyd, the great West Indies cricket captain. Shaquille O'Neal, yeah. Clive Lloyd, exactly. And it does have captain. Shaquille O'Neal, yeah, Clive Lloyd, exactly. And it does have an appeal among African-Americans, doesn't it? A surprising appeal among African-Americans. Yeah, the chapters about the States were the ones that I most enjoyed writing because despite Freemasonry's sort of enlightenment credo of racial, religious,
我的意思是，美国篮球运动员之类的。沙奎尔·奥尼尔。克莱·劳埃德，伟大的西印度群岛板球队长。沙奎尔·奥尼尔，是的。克莱·劳埃德，完全正确。它在非裔美国人中确实很有吸引力，不是吗？在非裔美国人中有着惊人的吸引力。是的，关于美国的章节是我写得最开心的，因为尽管共济会有着关于种族、宗教和
and social tolerance and so on and so on, the United States, really, right since the foundation of the American Republic, Freemasonry has been divided along racial lines because of racism, basically. The earliest black Freemasons, among whom was a man called Prince Hall, were prohibited from joining and founded their own tradition, now known as Prince Hall Freemasonry. And Prince Hall Freemasonry has an extraordinary record of involvement in the fight against slavery. You know, the first black troops to fight in the Civil War in 1863 were recruited, and most of their NCOs were Prince Hall Freemasons. Wow.
社会宽容等方面的启蒙运动信条，但自美国共和国成立以来，美国共济会实际上一直因为种族主义而按种族划界。最早的黑人共济会员中有一个叫普林斯·霍尔的人，他们被禁止加入，于是创立了自己的传统，现在被称为普林斯·霍尔共济会。而普林斯·霍尔共济会在参与反对奴隶制的斗争中有着非凡的记录。你知道，1863年在内战中战斗的第一批黑人军队是由他们招募的，他们的大多数士官都是普林斯·霍尔共济会员。哇。
You know, the civil rights movement is full of Freemasons. You know, the NAACP was largely funded by Masonic donations. Thurgood Marshall, who, you know, led the sort of brown verse of the Board of Education case, was a Prince Hall Freemason. Medgar Evers, you know from the bob dylan song or any opponent in their game and all that he he was a prince hall freemason rosa parks was a member of a female masonic organization and both her father and her grandfather were prince or Mason. So it's got a long history of involvement in civil rights and what they call uplift endeavors.
你知道，民权运动中到处都是共济会员。你知道，全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）很大程度上是由共济会捐款资助的。瑟古德·马歇尔——他领导了布朗诉教育委员会案——就是普林斯·霍尔共济会员。梅德加·埃弗斯——你知道鲍勃·迪伦的歌里唱过他，或者他们博弈中的对手等等——他也是普林斯·霍尔共济会员。罗莎·帕克斯是一个女性共济会组织的成员，她的父亲和祖父都是普林斯·霍尔共济会员。所以它有着悠久的参与民权运动和他们所谓的提升事业的历史。
Doesn't that tell you something about the nature of Masonry that actually it's a club for people who like joining and doing things and being activists and meeting like-minded people? And that ultimately more than anything else, more than the ritual. I mean, the rituals are fun for a lot of people. I mean, maybe there are people who believe in them, but I get the sense from your book, looking at the great span of Freemasonry, that actually it's clubbable.
这难道没有说明共济会的本质吗？它实际上是一个为那些喜欢加入、做事、当积极分子以及结识志同道合的人的人准备的俱乐部。最终，这比其他任何东西都重要，比仪式更重要。我的意思是，对很多人来说仪式很有趣，也许有人真的相信它们，但从你的书中，纵观共济会的漫长历史，我感觉它实际上是极具俱乐部性质的。
There's an awful lot of clubbable, public-spirited kind of people, and also people who are ambitious, who want to meet people who will help them, know italy or wherever well that's the core of it i wouldn't underestimate the power of that sense of the sacred you know he does tend to underestimate that right you know as i've tried to because i'm free missing partly about death and it's about coming to terms with death together with your mates uh in those rituals and that's you know that is at the core of many religions. Bertrand Russell said that the core work of all religion is dealing with fear. And we shouldn't forget as well that Freemasonry,
这里有大量具有俱乐部性质、热心公益的人，也有那些雄心勃勃、想要结识能够帮助他们的人，无论是去意大利还是其他地方。这才是核心，我不会低估那种神圣感的力量。你知道，人们往往会低估这一点，对吧？正如我试图做的那样，因为我不是共济会员。部分关于死亡，这是关于在这些仪式中与你的伙伴们一起接受死亡，你知道，那是许多宗教的核心。伯特兰·罗素说过，所有宗教的核心工作都是应对恐惧。我们也不应该忘记，共济会，
as well as in any, however we might define Freemasonry, in any sort of vaguely narrow sense, it's not just that that's influential. Freemasonry is an organizational template. This idea of a society of men, a brotherhood of men, fraternity, linked by rituals and a certain mythology, organized in cells, but with access to a much broader network, that's Freemasonry. But it also gives its origins to the Sicilian Mafia. You know, the Sicilian Mafia very much has Masonic DNA in its origins, in its beginnings.
正如任何……无论我们如何以狭义来定义共济会，它不仅仅是有影响力。共济会是一个组织模板。这种由男性组成的社会、男性兄弟会、通过仪式和特定神话联系在一起、以小组形式组织但能够接触到更广泛网络的理念，这就是共济会。但它也为西西里黑手党提供了起源。你知道，西西里黑手党的起源和开端中有着非常浓厚的共济会DNA。
And tons of other organizations have borrowed that Masonic template. The Ku Klux Klan, millions of other fraternal organizations, the Mormon Church, lots and lots of stuff. The early history of the Mormon Church and the history of Freemasonry are very closely intertwined. Such a fascinating way of, I mean, basically all post-18th century history is there to some degree, isn't it? There are Masons everywhere. You mentioned Roosevelt. What was Roosevelt? 32velt 32nd degree yeah that's right so he had gone through 32 rituals or whatever yeah although that is the scottish rite okay which is the most elaborate system of rituals and there are tons of these things uh but yeah i mean it's fairly these days it's fairly
还有无数其他组织都借鉴了这个共济会模板。三K党、数百万其他兄弟会组织、摩门教教会等等。摩门教的早期历史与共济会的历史紧密相连。这是一种如此迷人的方式——我的意思是，基本上所有18世纪以后的历史在某种程度上都包含在其中，不是吗？到处都有共济会员。你提到了罗斯福。罗斯福是什么？32度罗斯福，是的，没错。所以他经历了32个仪式之类的。是的，虽然那是苏格兰礼，也就是最复杂的仪式系统，而且有很多这类东西……但是的，我的意思是，如今经历这些
easy going through they make it easy for you to go through all those rituals. They're kind of performed for you. Often in packs, you know. But I mean, it's the list of, so let's end by just listing some of the people who've been maced. So five Kings of England, you say, 14 presidents of the United States, Robert Burns, Arthur Conan Doyle, Goethe, Mozart we've mentioned, Hayden, Sibelius, Arnold Palmer, Sugar Ray Robinson, Peter Sellers, Nat King Cole, Oliver Hardy, Henry Ford, Cecil Rose, Davy Crockett, Oscar Wilde, Walt Disney, Winston Churchill, Duke Ellington and the Duke of Wellington. Amazing. It is pretty amazing. So as Dominic said, all of history is there.
很容易，他们让你很容易就能经历所有这些仪式。它们是为你表演的。通常是成群结队的。但我的意思是，这些加入过共济会的名单……让我们以列举一些加入过共济会的人来结束吧：你说过有五位英国国王，14位美国总统，罗伯特·伯恩斯，阿瑟·柯南·道尔，歌德，我们提到的莫扎特，海顿，西贝柳斯，阿诺德·帕尔默，舒格·雷·鲁滨逊，彼得·塞勒斯，纳特·金·科尔，奥利弗·哈迪，亨利·福特，塞西尔·罗兹，戴维·克罗克特，奥斯卡·王尔德，华特·迪士尼，温斯顿·丘吉尔，艾灵顿公爵和威灵顿公爵。太惊人了。确实非常惊人。正如多米尼克所说，所有的历史都在其中。
And your book is kind of therefore not just about the freemasons but about the world since the early modern period so that's the craft how the freemasons made the modern world um john thanks so much it was absolutely wonderful my pleasure and of course if you've listened to this and you think it was a bit too soft on freemasonry then that's that's proof that we're all secretly masons we We've been lying to you all along. And if you think we've been too harsh, then you're a mason and you know that we're not. So everybody's a winner. Everybody will come away.
所以你的书不仅是关于共济会的，也是关于近代以来的世界的。这就是共济会如何塑造现代世界的，约翰，非常感谢，这绝对太棒了。我的荣幸。当然，如果你听了这些，觉得对共济会太温和了，那这就是我们都是秘密共济会员的证据。我们一直在对你撒谎。如果你觉得我们太严厉了，那你就是个共济会员，你知道我们不是。所以每个人都是赢家。每个人都会离开时……
Everyone comes away a little bit disappointed, which is how we like it on The Rest Is History. And on that note, thank you, John. And goodbye, everybody. We'll see you next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
每个人离开时都会感到略有一点失望，这也是我们在《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）中喜欢的方式。伴随着这一点，谢谢你，约翰。大家再见。我们下次见。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听额外节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。